hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast exploring co2 and ethanol
extraction technology and history
presented by Fritz chess the founder and
chief scientist at Eden labs I am Judy
O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinths laberd's is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box it
appears on this screen we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the help
desk button located in the promotional
board at the bottom center of your
screen or use the ask a question box to
let us know that you're having a problem
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming
Fritz chess I will now turn the
presentation over to him hello
eating laughs is primarily an equipment
manufacturer for botanical extraction we
specialize in supercritical co2 in
ethanol extraction we also have an R&D
lab where people can come to us where
they have product they're looking to
bring the market or a process they're
hoping to develop we can work on that
and help them refine the process or make
it happen and then maybe produce the
equivalent of some customized equipment
or their particular needs
on top of that we have standard systems
that we sell and build on a regular
basis behind me I have one of our five
liter co2 extractors very common for the
herbal medicine industry in the cannabis
industry we also make ethanol extraction
equipment which actually started eating
labs our coldfinger extractors were
redesigned in 1995 of the Sox like
extractor
the socks of extractor was basically the
only extractor on the market for
small-scale extractions it was developed
by franz von Schaack slick in 1921 and
agricultural chemist and that's kind of
what started eating labs as I could see
ways to improve the socks of extractor
design that launched our colon fingers
which we still sell to this day along
with our co2 extraction systems cold
fingers can be anything from a little
table top extraction unit up to 500
gallon models that do 350 pounds at a
time so co2 extraction you know people
think of co2 as a gas and it typically
is in the atmosphere it's what it's what
feeds plants it's what plants breathe
then we breathe out co2 plants breathe
it in will we take co2 in a pure state
and you compress it at a certain point
it becomes a liquid and that's one way
to do a co2 extraction becomes a
non-polar solvent when it's in its
liquid phase and then it can be
pressurized and heated further to what's
called a supercritical phase where it
becomes if you could see it it would
look like a dense fog and the polarities
and the extraction properties of
supercritical co2 change as temperature
and pressure is increased at very high
pressures it becomes less polar so the
nice thing about u2 is by adjusting
temperatures and pressures you can pull
different compounds
out of the plan which makes it very
useful for a lot of different industries
and types of extraction the history of
eating I cover down a little bit in 1995
we came out with the coldfinger
extractors and basically as soon as I
started doing that I became aware of co2
extraction started looking at how other
people were doing it and it seemed like
everybody was making it too complicated
so what what myself and Eaton look to
accomplish was to have a much simpler
more maintenance-free unit that anybody
could operate and you know the idea was
for a farmer who wanted to extract some
of the products that he was growing with
a system that didn't require a chemical
engineer to operate and could be easily
fixed by anyone who can fix a tractor
you know or fix a piece of farm
equipment and that's how that's how the
eating systems came about and they have
accomplished that goal they're simple
and easy to operate they almost never
break and they do a really good job and
they tend to be faster than most of the
other systems that are on the market and
that's important because co2 extraction
is not typically a real fast process
compared to some of the more aggressive
solvents that are you know flammable and
more dangerous like xane so we didn't
figure out a way to make it go about as
fast as you can make it so flow matters
because the faster the flow generally
the faster your dinner extraction the
faster your extraction of a certain
point you will just flow over the
material without extracting anything so
we have optimized flow rate to where we
can get the most oil out of a plant
without going too fast and just flowing
over and we can do that in such a way
that we're not damaging and you the
delicate components of a plant like the
terpenes and we take great
I and the fact that we figured out flow
because it's very complicated in the
separators which is holes that could be
a whole nother presentation one time
though so density density basically
means just how thick that co2 that
supercritical co2 is or subcritical
liquid co2 the density affects you know
the solubility of the compounds you're
working with so you can calculate
density by temperature and pressure
plenty of charts for that and then you
can figure out the solubilities of the
plants you're working with and in some
of the more advanced systems and we do
make these where you have multiple
separators you can you can extract a
high pressure get a lot of things out
and then instead of all the oil dropping
into just one separator you know
multiple separators where the densities
change cascading downwards and the
separators and you can get pretty good
the typical scenarios waxes and
chlorophylls that you don't want and
that tend to drop out at higher
densities those will drop out in the
first separator the heart of the oil
usually the main product that you want
in a second separator and then the light
terpenes or essential oils where all the
fragrances would be in the third
separate so même labs first started
doing this as I said earlier we built
the system to be as simple as possible
as little to break as possible and so
that anybody could work on them and we
accomplished them we have the only or we
have the only co2 system that just
doesn't break in the beginning we
avoided automation because everybody can
remember their early computers and the
night bees cell phone they didn't work
so great but automation is now pretty
much a refined industry and we now have
on products if you choose that like that
on your system our automation is a
little unique and that not only is just
thing where you can press a button and
it does most of the work for you but we
have programmable systems where you can
optimize your yields your extraction
time you can dropout terpenes the light
oils early in the run and then get heavy
folio resins during the run so and
another thing many of the other systems
there's basically four programs and
that's all you can do with it if you
decide you want to change a battle you
can't do it ours have an analogue option
to where you suddenly decide you need to
change this valve or you need to change
that you can override the system or do
that so it has the advantages of both so
what's the city the main thing about a
co2 system they do work under extremely
high pressure so what even Labs has done
where we never cut a corner is in our
pressure vessels they have what's called
a four time safety factor that means
that the operating pressure may be the
operating pressure of the vessel is
2,000 psi
but that vessel would not fail till it
gets to 8,000 psi so the systems are
extremely safe but that's an area where
a lot of people cut corners where their
safety factor might only be one and a
half or even one and a quarter because
using that thinner metal saves money and
you know the the lower pressure rated
vessels are easier to open so they're
for sacrificing safety for convenience
so the kind of products you can make
what's uni - well a lot Papias
decapitate what's you know - fragrances
flavorings co2 has become very popular
with the cannabis industry and
the reasons for that is you know it's a
very efficient system it's from an
operator standpoint your your facility
does not get that messy because you're
not dealing with hot wet flammable
solvents you know when you take the
system apart you're you're just
vacuuming out dry material but it's also
very good for making the bait pen olive
oil that's become so popular and it's by
far the best way to get the terpenes you
know where all the flavor and the aroma
is there's just no better way to do it
so now we're going to look death annul
expression going back to our roots and
one of the reasons we're covering that
is because ethanol extraction is now
having a Renaissance up until 2010
particularly for the cannabis industry
mostly what we sold were our coldfinger
systems a many some suddenly in 2010
everybody wanted to see their - and the
company was just oriented around making
a lot of co2 now people have realized
that ethanol is extremely efficient
solvent it strips cannabinoids out of
the cannabis material very quickly and
[Music]
because because a lot of extracts are
being refined even though the ethanol
may pull other things that you don't
want it's going through several stages
of refinement anyway so it doesn't
matter what your first stage of
extraction but then the other reason
that ethanol has become so popular is
it's been discovered that if you get
that and all really cold it still does a
pretty quick extraction and it comes out
fairly well refined Falls very few waxes
or fats or chlorophyll sometimes the
yields might be a little lower but you
always have the option of you know doing
something more aggressive you have to
get that last out like higher ethanol
alder or another song
so another one of our methods is stirred
reactive
going back in history when you think of
you know early days of stirring or
backing of botanical you simply took the
plant material put it in a boiling water
and that was a wreck attraction make
basically make a thick tea that you
drink so an industrial way of doing this
is what's called a stirred reactor it's
some of the most common way to extract
any herb on earth stirred reactors are
used for any number of different
processes basically you just have a
basket filled with herb that lowers into
a vessel then it's it's filled with
small and meeting the stern usually for
about 90 minutes and then drained off
our big distillers have the option of
being used is stirred reactors well we
hear from companies to do multiple
herbal extracts like medicinal herbs
they'll swear that you know maybe cat's
claw extracts best with the coldfinger
process where you're where you're
distilling the solvent it's just slowly
dripping through this basket but you
know maybe the herb amate and I'm just
throwing out examples but maybe they are
mamata a somehow comes out better when
you use the stirred reactor process so
these commercial distillers of ours that
have multiple ways of using them they're
they're pretty popular in the herbal
medicine industrial like the kind of
things you'd see a super supplements or
a whole food store a lot of those
products are made with our our large
industrial commercial distiller
extractors I'm going back into the
history of the coldfinger extraction
there were there were two things that I
studied when I was looking for a way to
make my own extractor it was the ISO 2
which was developed by a gentleman named
DJ Gould and he sold it I times in mid
70s it was a good working unit
but you know it was made out of aluminum
I didn't like that you know aluminum is
uh easily copy you know cause there's a
lot of solvents and acids are caustic on
it and so the risk of having lumen in
your product and and the condenser
wasn't very efficient it lost eleven
solvent you know eating with a the
heater was a light ball and but I
studied that because it was a working
unit because they had marketed those of
high times as a way of extracting pot
and the DEA came in and shut them down
real quick they they're only in high
times for a little while when I was a
kid so we were very careful about how we
marketed extractors in the early days
before it was legal basically we almost
kind of in a tongue-in-cheek we said
warning this is not to be able to used
for illegal purposes it's kind of a
roundabout way of saying hey you can
make actually and as I mentioned earlier
we also studied the socks of extractor
and so the cold finger kind of borrowed
some of the principles from those two
extractors but also made some
improvements because both of those
extractors that's influence of course
you know what I call them distillers
they can be used for conventional
distilling such as steam distilling
herbs get an essential oil for making
fine liquors we can put distilling
columns on them for making gin vodka
bourbon and that sort of thing or just
industrial recovery of solvents we can
make a falling film system and also stir
the whole thing so that we can create a
lot of vapor and pull it off in a hurry
basically you just want a big distiller
they recover solvents quickly we have
accessories for doing that as well
one of our new accessories for the
distillers is what we call cold snap and
that is an adaptation for the the cold
ethanol phenomenon that's taking place
what's nice about the cold snap is
basically we have a cooled column that
we can put the herb in and it sits on
top of the distiller and you can just
use vacuum against the distiller to pull
the cold ethanol through the column as
it passes through the herb well we have
a glass one where you can just see the
extraction taking place in the column
which is really cool just watching the
greener suddenly have all this gold
orange liquid surrounding it and then
that comes through into the distiller
itself or with the melons we have a
sight glass where you can see the color
coming through the side glass and by
watching the color changes you know what
kind of fraction of the extraction
you're getting and you know when the
best fraction comes through and starts
to change you can close a valve and
separate that so you know you can make a
grade A and grade the fraction the cold
snap was really developed for the
cannabis industry but we're discovering
that it's also useful for a lot of other
herbs particularly just another way to
get length terpenes out of herbs we can
do that cold and leave other stuff
behind so it's a great new innovation
that we're just we've just recently
I guess that's the end of the program if
anybody has any questions I'd be having
answered Thank You Fred's for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button well answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for so let's get started our first
question is what yield can you expect
from your systems well the simple answer
whatever the Constituent is that's in
your plant material however much is
there you know we can get it out now
that's actually a question that's driven
me crazy for 23 years because I I might
get a call from a guy say in India and
he's talking about a nerve I've never
heard of in India ask me what kind of
yield I can get obviously that's a silly
question I don't know anything about
your plant I don't know what the
constituent heads are how much is in
there um you know these days you know a
lot of our business is cannabis and
people ask that question I can make if I
can see your cannabis I can make a
pretty educated guess but you know just
getting real basic fan leaves one to two
maybe three percent can I have a no
leads in it good trim like the sugar
trail can be 15 to 18 percent tops you
know 12 to 18 and you know the very best
dense really bugs light at 30 percent
that's kind of a record but in short the
way even lab systems are designed if you
run them properly and you run them long
enough you will get everything out we
have had lab testing that showed 100
percent cover e of yields in fact we
just did an extraction in our R&D system
for an herb called cap mint and the oil
is going to be used as an insect
repellent and they were only getting a
1%
needled with the extraction system they
had we got 11% so we anticipating they
said they wanted a big factory to
process the scatman hoping we're gonna
get a big factory because we they're
pretty distilled by 10%
thank you your next one is can you scale
as they grow yes as far as companies
that make extraction systems were one of
the only ones who can do anything from a
little stovetop unit that you can
operate in your kitchen up to a big
industrial factory they could do six
tons of herbs a day and anything in
between we have our standard systems the
range up to you know either a 500 gallon
distiller or a you know a 100 liter or 2
by 100 liter co2 extractor anything
bigger than that whether it's alcohol or
co2 it's gonna be a custom system we're
gonna need to engineer it for you and in
design and we can design the facility as
well we have all the connections to
bring in all the material handling like
if you need conveyor belts and the HVAC
systems we have the experience and we
can give people a tour of a ops plant in
Yakima designed by our Chemical Engineer
six tons of hops very well I would like
to once again thank fritz Jess for his
presentation I would also like to thank
lab roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June 29th 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab herbs letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us we hope to see
you again soon bye